hello everyone a very warm greeting to
one and all my name is Sri gavri Krishna
Kumar and I would like to welcome you
all for the second webinar on microbiome
in Health and Wellness hackathon so for
those of you who are new to this webinar
welcome and we are organizing a
hackathon on microbiome in health and
wellness this November to provide
students with a platform to Showcase
their Innovative mindset of problem
solving and in this hackathon each
student will have the opportunity to
develop a mini project around the
hackathon topic from a team with at
least two other students and compete
against others for mentorship support
from established companies and long-term
interests from the business community
and the applications of hackathon are in
the fields of obesity and Precision
Nutrition Innovation and beauty products
and pregnancy
in our previous webinar we discussed
week one topics on microbiome business
that will that will be covered during
the training duration we were joined by
Mr Elia brotsky CEO of spine biotech who
discussed what the hackathon is about
what kind of opportunities are present
for students and researchers who are
participating in the hackathon the
participants of the webinar they are
also joined by Dr agavendra Lakshmi
Narayan computational biologists and
research consultant at Pine biotech he
discussed what is microbiome how
bioinformatic approaches help understand
Association of microbial population with
disease and popular research
Publications that will provide ideas for
students participating in the hackathon
in today's webinar we will be first
introducing the participants to the week
2 workshop on biotechnology where we
will be covering the topics on gut
microbiome health and diet skin
microbiome Beauty comfort and aging and
vaginal microbiome pregnancy and
symptoms
so before we begin with today's webinar
for those of you who are joining for the
first time let me also take a brief
moment to introduce you to the team
behind the program we are a us-based
branchmatics company who is working with
multiple academic and Commercial
collaborators to develop easy to use
analytical tools and our mission is to
make bioinformatics more accessible
and as a part of the hackathon students
will have access to the omics logic
training that has been completed by over
24 000 participants from 187 countries
in over 300 workshops and due to this
fast quote our team is working with
local and Regional coordinators that are
helping refine local program Logistics
and adapting them to the needs of
students and researchers around the
world and this training has been
completed by participants in six
different specialization tracks that
includes oncology infectious diseases
Precision medicine Neuroscience data
science for biomedical data and
comprehensive training on omic's data
analysis
as a part of the hackathon students will
also have access to the omics logic
resources but how does it help
advancements teaching omox logic is a
portal for practical and theoretical
learning of bandformatics it takes a
combination of frame modules data
analysis tools curated project data sets
and interactive sessions with mentors to
give the student a clear path of the
blooms taxonomy permit no matter what
the user's initial experience with
bioinformatics is omic's logic is a
useful tool for gaining a baseline
knowledge of the theory behind
bioinformatics analysis of data sets and
introduction to basic coding languages
like R and python or even beginning a
data analysis project
this also comes with an access to all
mixed logic courses which includes
courses on bioinformatics Precision
medicine multiomics including genomics
transcriptomics metagenomics epigenomics
data science that includes
bioinformatics using iron python as well
as chem informatics users will be given
directions to access the T by info
platform for benchmatic processing and
Analysis of data and the platform
includes demo pipelines as well as data
management and Analysis Cloud
infrastructure to run the bioinformatic
pipeline and different stages of the
analysis are performed in different
sections on this multinomics platform
so first of all we need to sign up on
the omics project run portal but before
that let me walk you through a brief
demo on what a completed profile on the
portal looks like
once you sign up on the portal these are
the features that you need to update on
your account that is a completed profile
will have a profile image full name with
appropriate capitalization linked to
your social media handles this could be
your Facebook LinkedIn Instagram or
kaidi or even Twitter a brief bio about
yourself that will consist of your
education background and research
interests the mentors can view your
progress under the activity tab the
courses you are currently completing
will appear under the courses Tab and
finally after the completion of your
course the certificates will appear
under the certificates tab once you sign
up on the portal you will also be able
to view the various courses and example
projects that will help you prepare for
the hackathon one course that I would
like to bring to your notice whether you
are a beginner to the field of matter
genomics or you're an intermediate or
expert willing to refresh your meta
genome Concepts I would like to direct
you to course 2 bytes and molecules this
course is intended for all those who are
interested in understanding how the
current revolution in biomedical data
impacts biomedical research and human
health in this course the lesson that
will be of relevance for the
participants will be lesson 8
introduction to metagenomics in this
lesson we will explore how different
types of analysis can be used to
understand the microbial world and
practice several biasmatical approaches
to the analysis of the microbiome
finally to check your understanding the
lesson ends with a simple quiz if you
wish to proceed ahead and gain an
in-depth understanding of the
metagenomic concepts you can opt for
Cores for metagenomics in this course
you will learn about processing 16s rrna
data with data to visualizing o2u
abundant stables for diversity using
phyloc are package that can help build
phylogeny aware species richness Alpha
diversity plots and beta diversity plots
and so much more to help build these
concept course use practical quizzes
Hands-On demo pipelines and our
programming for data visualization
once you gain a thorough understanding
of the key concept involved in the
metagenomics data analysis one can start
by going through one of the relevant
example project the example projects are
sourced from high impact research
Publications that will provide students
with the logic behind conducting a
research topic for instance the example
project on role of high fat diet on
Obesity aims to understand the microbial
diversity after feeding high fat and
normal diet in mice and decipher its
role in obesity and underlying diseases
all the example projects follows a
similar format where students are
initially given an overview of the
important Concepts to carry out the
example project this is followed by
identifying a gap in the literature and
understanding the significance of the
research question proposed once done the
students knowledge are tested through
quizzes and assignments to provide
Hands-On practical experience students
are given step-by-step guideline to
building bioinformatic pipelines on the
T bioinfo server and this section that
will be available for today's discussion
is the metagenomic section
for this example project they're already
accessed a demo pipeline under the name
ciao versus HRT in this example we are
making use of 16 is metal genomic
pipeline
this is an example of how we will carry
out the balance Max Pipeline the input
files will consist of pickle samples
collected from the mice and our aim here
is to analyze the microbial microbial
diversity the pipeline is based on
running a number of programs including
data 2 a and phylo seek and the
functions of each of these algorithms
have been thoroughly explained in the
course after running the pipeline we
received several outputs including file
of c bar plot abundance table file of
sleep abundance plot abundance heat map
whose interpretation has been explained
as well in the course the course also
introduces the Learners to perform in
Downstream analysis of 16s amplicon data
using our programming and how to
interpret the resulting output
some of the other example projects that
one could look into are effective
dietary fiber intake or microbiome this
example project aims to determine the
microbial composition of obese and
normal weight subjects and identify
microbial changes after weight loss diet
another interesting project that one
could look into is the effect of
non-antibiotics and wet syndrome this
example project aims to understand the
change changes in microbial Community
after the administration of
non-antibiotic drugs to understand how
they affect the neurological dysfunction
so now you might be wondering what comes
after the courses after completing the
courses and example projects and the
answer is possibilities are endless for
instance you could go on to perform a
research project like this a
bioinformatics graduate from Amity uni
University Rajasthan who completed a
research project on the composition of
gut microbiota of samples infected with
liver cancer she uploaded a project on
Blown portal where an International
Community of students peers and
bioinformatics experts can watch her
presentation recording read through the
research project like share and comment
their feedback under the comment section
another interesting student project
outcome can be seen in case of de la
retaking a molecular biology and
genetics graduate from University of
turkey who completed a project on
metagenomics and Astronaut Health which
she went on to present at the scionics
club session a session where an
International Learning Community of
bioinformatic enthusiasts come together
to share their work debate on important
topics and share their queries to stay
up to date with latest advancements in
the field in addition she she also went
on to publish her project as a preprint
on bioarchive that she can share with
her peers mentors and potential
employers for future connections
further you could also participate in
research Symposium and showcase your
work such as omics research Symposium
where one of the participants who
presented her project on comparison of
microbiome data of different lung
diseases on cash prices for the first
price for best technical research
project this Symposium is an
international research Symposium that
brings together experts such as Dr
Garrett trouble staff scientist at
Lawrence Livermore National Laboratory
and Dr Joseph Borg associate professor
and principal investigator at University
of Malta amongst so many other experts
who join as guest speakers and judges so
to view courses and example projects
various programs student project let us
Begin by signing up on the Onyx logic
learn photo for that I'm sharing the
link in the chat box please click on the
link and I'll walk you through the
process behind signing up on the portal
so here is the link
so
all right so once you click on the link
you'll be able to view the omic
Strategic learns sign up page for users
who do not have an existing account on
the portal you can click on the create
an account option that you see here
and here you will be asked to enter your
name email ID providing your password
you can also have the option to sign up
using any of your social media accounts
such as Google Facebook Apple account
GitHub account or even Twitter
so with that I will pause for a couple
of minutes so that the participants can
visit the page and start signing up on
the portal if you are facing any
technical issues please put them in the
chat as well so that I can help you for
signing up on the portal
once you have signed up on the portal
please put a yes in the chat box so that
I know we are good to proceed
so I'm monitoring the chat box mean time
all right the laba has already signed up
Mansi has also signed up
so we have more than 25 plus
participants and I am expecting a yes
from almost all of them
if you are facing any queries you could
put them in the chat as well
so since I already have an account on
the portal I'm going to click on the
login now option
so here I could just click on the sign
in and I could
enter the code so once you sign up you
first enter the courses tab page here if
you scroll down and here if it will ask
for if you're looking for a specific
course so since most of the participants
are interested in the meta genomics
field I'm going to enter the keyword
that is metagenomics there you go you
have the course and the various example
projects that you could uh visit and
check and you could start taking so one
of the important part that I explained
before was uh like was to set up your
profile for that click on the tab that
says welcome back with your email ID and
here you will be able to see the icon
that says profile here you will be able
to enter your details such as your
educational background research
interests your name and in my case I've
linked my LinkedIn account and my old id
so under the activity tab the mentor and
the community manager will be able to
track your learning progress under the
courses tab
the participants will be able to view
the various courses that they are
currently taking so for instance I just
recently started taking up the example
project on non-antibiotics and red
syndrome is really interesting project
and I would highly urge all of you to
check it out and once you've complete a
research project like Ghazal you can
upload it under the project staff and if
you wish to enroll for any of the
programs and then you'll be able to view
the programs under the programs Tab and
finally after the completion of the
courses you will be able to receive the
certificates under the certificates tab
and finally to view the various student
projects you can click on the projects
tab that you see here and you could see
a wide variety of projects on oncology
Neuroscience Agriculture and so on so
now I'd like to pass on the stage to one
of my colleagues sonalika Ray who will
be explaining how you can leverage the
technical resources that are available
on the T by engine platform so over to
you sonalika